a good magician might never reveal their
secrets but we're ready to expose some
magical secrets and show you what goes
on behind the scenes of really simple
magic tricks you can do these at home or
at school to impress your friends stick
around to see how to bend a solid coin
using nothing but your hands if you're
new to our channel make sure to give
this video a thumbs up and subscribe
today we're revealing 10 easy magic
tricks anyone can do missing finger this
is the old trick with a misplaced thumb
also commonly known as the thumb thing
if you have a fun uncle or a grandpa we
bet you've seen this trick in live
action even though magicians never
reveal their secrets we're bending that
rule just for you we promise it's going
to work we recommend you practice this
one with a mirror to make sure your
magic trick will turn out perfect lift
your left hand and face the back towards
your audience then take your first
finger and thumb of your right hand and
pinch your thumb of your left hand at
the knuckle pretend you're pulling hard
on the left thumb and tell your audience
you just need to do it to get a tight
grip this is the part where you do your
trick bend your left thumb down and your
right thumb to the right when you put
the knuckles together it will look like
you have a large thumb then you just
need to make sure you're separating the
gap between the knuckles to do that just
use your first finger of your right hand
all you need to do now is slide your
right hand with the thumb all while
making sure your finger still covers
that gap where the knuckles touch it
takes a while to practice but we promise
it's totally worth it don't forget to be
extremely convincing with your facial
expressions turn water into ice we might
not be able to turn water into wine but
this is the next best thing this trick
is not even magic it's just pure science
it's completely mind-blowing and it
might take you a few tries before you
get it just right but we promise that
it's worth it it's described as the
super cooling phenomenon which happens
when the temperature of a liquid
substance goes below the normal freezing
point but it doesn't really freeze what
you'll need is a freezer and a bottle of
purified water let the bottles sit in
the freezer for about two or three hours
but make sure it doesn't freeze then
take it out if it works you'll be able
to just tap on the water bottle and the
liquid will start turning into ice you
can also try another trick that's
equally as impressive grab a bowl and
fill with
cubes then take out your water bottle
from the freezer open it and pour it all
over the ice what will happen is the
water will begin to crystallize and
create this awesome effect of becoming
solid in just seconds you can also pour
yourself a glass of water and drop in
the crystallized ice the water will
instantly become chill we're telling you
this is the trick to use if you're
looking to impress your friends defy
gravity we bet you've seen the
mind-blowing trick with the rubber band
in the ring before this is a fun one to
do if you're looking to win a bet
because no one will believe you can pull
this off the magician takes the rubber
band and puts on a ring but then he
turns the rubber band downward you'd
expect the ring to fall down but this
magic trick defies gravity so how is the
magician able to make that ring go up
and set it down well it's actually the
material of the rubber band that does
the trick and it's really easy so grab a
rubber band and lightly stretch it it
doesn't have to be all the way but about
12 inches between your hands hold most
of it in your left hand so you end up
with a loose piece in your left palm
then tell your friends you can make the
ring go up instead of fall down what
you'll do next is ease the grip on the
rubber band with your left fingers and
just release some of the pressure you'll
notice the ring will start slowly moving
up and creating a cool effect of defying
gravity continue doing this in very
small motions and you'll be able to
bring the ring all the way up then get
ready to win some bets with your friends
a floating coffee cup another fun trick
to pull off on your friends is the
floating coffee cup this one is very
popular if you want to impress the
person you like or if you're just
looking to have some fun
if you thought there's no way you can
make a cup levitate you were wrong
here's what you'll need to make this
work
grab a Styrofoam cup and you're good to
go this one is best to practice in front
of a mirror so you can make sure you
don't actually reveal your secret poke a
hole with your thumb into the coffee cup
and face the thumb right in front of the
person you're showing the trick to
slowly lift the cup and make it lightly
shake make sure your other hand also
mimics the cups movements this will
create an optical illusion and the
audience will just think you're using
both of your hands to control the cup
and make it float in reality is the
secret thumb that does the job to make
this trick even more convincing you can
hand the cup over to your friends before
you show them the magic magicians also
love to talk about static
electricity and preparing their set with
a few hand movements to make it even
more convincing after a few tries you'll
really master it and we bet you'll be
able to convince your family and your
friends jumping rubber band did you know
you can make a rubber band jump from
finger to finger in just seconds we're
not joking this trick is guaranteed to
impress your crush or your friends it's
really simple and all it requires is a
little bit of practice and you'll be
ready to put on a show so grab a rubber
band and let's start practicing but
first let us tell you how it works put
the rubber band over the first and
second finger of your left hand face
your hand with your palm upwards and
stretch the rubber band with your right
hand make sure you do this quickly
enough so the audience doesn't see it
then bend your fingers and make sure
they're facing you then carefully place
the band across all four fingers and
make sure it's placed below the first
knuckle then all you need to do is open
your hands and if the rubber band is
placed correctly it'll jump on the next
two fingers you can create an awesome
show by telling your audience to blow in
your fist right before you open your
hand the rubber band will instantly jump
on the next set of fingers with a little
bit of practice you can become extremely
good at this and we bet your friends
will be impressed by your awesome magic
skills spin a playing card midair
everyone loves a levitating magic trick
it's hard to believe regular humans are
able to pull off something like a
levitating object but if you practice
hard you can become really good at it
you've probably seen the playing card
being spun in midair before and the
thing is this is actually one of the
easiest magic tricks you can do grab a
playing card a thread and some clear
adhesive tape the thinner your thread is
the better you could even do this with a
strand of your hair attach the thread to
the center of the playing card and put
the other end of the thread on something
like a shirt button or your watch form a
loop in the thread and wrap it around
the button the length of the thread
should leave your card hanging about a
foot below your hand but make sure the
thread is set between your fingers this
will create the impression that your
hand is actually the one that's
controlling the spinning then just throw
the card like a frisbee and watch it
spin it will take some practice to
really pull off the card spinning motion
but we promise it'll all be worth it
make sure your friends don't stand too
close as they'll be able to see the
thread magnetic pencil you've seen this
one before too right where someone grabs
the pencil and then out stretches their
hand but the pencil is somehow magically
stuck to their hand well it's not all
mine
this one is actually the simplest trek
out of the ones we're showing you today
all you'll need for this one is a pencil
in your own hands start off this trick
by showing your audience that if you
grip the pencil and then let it go it
will fall seems like the basic law of
gravity right well with this magic trick
you can really ignore the gravity and
show people that just because you let go
of the pencil it doesn't mean it'll let
go of your hand
here's how to actually do it right
before releasing your grip place the
index finger of your other hand on the
pencil the best way to do this is to
gently hold your wrist and make it seem
like it's the strength you need to make
this trick work what will happen next is
that the finger will still be keeping
the pencil in the same place even though
your hands will be now outstretched make
sure your hands are low enough so your
audience won't be able to see the secret
finger and have a firm grip on your
pencil put on a show and voila you've
just created some magic color-changing
cards we all know playing cards have
different colors on the back but
magicians often pull the trick of having
the same cards change their color with
just the snap of their finger let's see
how it's done it's actually so simple
you can easily recreate this yourself
here's how this works
grab a deck of cards with the same color
on the back then get just one card with
a different color for example if you've
picked the two of spades you'll need to
also find the two of spades in the other
pile place those cards at the bottom of
your pile spread the pile but make sure
you aren't revealing the last few cards
this will make sure your audience
doesn't end up picking those cards as
they're crucial to this magic trick once
the card is picked place the bottom half
of the pile in your right hand put the
person's card on top of the left hand
pile and place the right hand pile on
top of it then spread the pile again it
should now have one different colored
back of the card claim that this is the
card the person picked remember the
picked card is now on the bottom of the
different colored card all you have to
do now is lift both of them and make it
look like it's a single card with a
changed color on the back
voila the magic is done peel a sliced
banana cutting up fruit is noise fun but
imagine if you could just buy sliced
bananas still in there peel this is a
fun trick to do if you have younger
siblings or kids who will never believe
that you can actually peel and already
sliced banana but in the world of magic
everything is possible there are several
ways you can make this work grab a
needle and carefully place it in the
banana the
your needle the better then move it back
and forth without damaging the outer
peel repeat this process all the way
down and you'll end up with a banana
that's already sliced simple right
another way to do this and create cool
shapes is using a needle and a thread
instead of piercing the banana all the
way through push the needle just a
couple of inches on one side do this all
the way around the banana and then exit
the needle through the original entry
hole pull the thread and you'll end up
with a pre sliced banana that's yet to
be peeled if you know your way around
the needle and thread you can easily
slice the banana in a spiral or even
create stars and other exciting shapes
to others this will look like complete
magic and only you'll know the real
reason why that banana is already sliced
bend a coin apart from levitating
objects and changing the color of
playing cards one of the most exciting
tricks is to bend completely solid
objects do you know how to bend a coin
we'll show you how you can impress
people with your super strength and show
them this impressive magic trick this
one is a little sneaky but it requires a
lot of practice to get it done perfectly
here's what you'll need
grab two coins usually a quarters work
best but any smaller coins will do the
trick is you'll have to make your bent
quarter before hand you can easily do so
by taking two pliers hold them on each
side of the quarter and just use some
strength to push them down it should
slowly Bend without any problems hide
your bent quarter in your palm then show
your audience that your coin is pretty
solid and there's no way this would work
without magic here comes the hardest
part without anyone noticing switch the
two coins cover the bottom half and
start giving the illusion of bending the
quarter then all you have to do is show
the finished result which is the quarter
you've bent before you even started
showing this trick make sure to avoid
any sounds the two coins could make as
you do the switch and of course practice
to make sure your coin never falls out
of your hand
what's your favorite magic trick let us
know in the comments for more videos
like this one check out fifteen random
acts of vandalism that are pure genius
see you next time
[Music]